it's friday how about unwinding with a
margarita
jc fernandez is live at husson's mexican
cantina with the details on their big
anniversary celebration hey jaycee
hey christian is a huge celebration
happening today this is heidi
heidi tell everyone that's watching
about some of the great specials that
you guys have down here today
absolutely we have bogo margaritas buy
one get one free
our happy hour nachos are five dollars
all day
no these are legendary nachos by the way
iconic wasang's nachos
just five dollars you gotta you gotta
suck those down today
they're amazing and then also too it's
the january as well
the january yes our veganuary special
is our barbecued chipotle
enchiladas it's got vegan rice vegan
beans
vegan ranch vegan cheese i'm sorry vegan
sour cream vegan cheese
delicious 100 vegan for veganuary and
when you
when you buy one of these a little bit
goes to a charity
that's perfect and she mentioned buy one
margarita get one free when you come
down here tonight
you guys are known for your margaritas
you invented the margarita show us all
how to make one i'll follow along okay
absolutely so first we take our glass
dip it in our agave agave and if you're
watching you can do this at home too you
guys actually have this on your facebook
page on how to make
the proper who songs margarita that's
all there we go let's put it there oh
beautiful
perfect now you've got your shaker
filled with ice got it with ice already
okay we're going to do one shot of lime
one shot of lime yeah it looks like a
shot
that works you good perfect nice pick up
your tequila bottle we're going to do
shoe shots there
is this the tequila yeah all right here
we go two
shots of tequila what we'll do this
right here okay
we want to have some fun here so we got
the crowd over there likes it they're
here
they're here cheering me on the jc
fernandez margarita okay so what's next
we got our fresh agave
agave one quarter okay okay
and our triple sack a little bit quarter
of that
yeah triple sec there's alcohol in
triple sec right okay a little out that
goes in here
you're drinking that one by the way no
no no no listen i want to function
tomorrow okay
all right let's cap up our shaker well
this could be trouble when i shake on my
actual margarita don't hit me please
do you guys see tom cruise
and look at that the perfect
margarita oh you need a lime lime drop
it in there thank you
the perfect margarita now does that
cheers the sad thing is
the jc fernandez margarita is not
available at who songs but your
margaritas are equally as delicious
thank you thank you so much enjoy the
11th year anniversary celebration
it's happening today only so come down
here and have some fun we'll send them
back to you guys in the studio
cheers